a scathing new report reveals boeing
engineers and
pilots warned about the potential
dangers of the trouble 737 max jet
years before two deadly crashes former
employees told democrats on the house
transportation committee
they expressed concern about the plan's
anti-stall system but it was never fixed
that system is suspected in crashes in
2018 and 2019 that killed 346 people in
all
last year then boeing ceo dennis
meudelberg was asked
why the 737 max wasn't grounded after
the first deadly incident
if we knew everything back then that we
know now
we would have made a difference okay the
question then did people come to you
the report also finds the plane was
given the okay to fly
by the faa even though it was ultimately
proved
unsafe the faa says it will work with
the house committee to
implement improvements identified in its
report boeing says it has made changes
to its 737 max fleet based on feedback
from multiple committees
experts and governmental authorities
transportation correspondent chris van
cleave
has been on this story since it began
and will continue to keep you
all updated yeah part of the controversy
here and something our investigative
unit has looked at is that the faa may
some people say become too cozy with the
airlines that they're supposed to be
reviewing and so you get a safety
approval and then it turns out it's not
safe
yeah there's people on top of that